فعليا لم يتعافى العالم بعد كليا من جائحه
كورونا وما زال يناور امام الفيروس
باللقاحات والتطعيمات المعززه اي ان
الفيروس موجود بيننا وضع عباره اخرى نكاد
نتعايش مع وجوده وحتى مع متحولاته لكن
الصين والتي قيل قبل ثلاث سنوات انها من
نشرت الوباء من وهان البؤره الاولى للمرض
فقد سم اهلها من سياسه صفر كوفد الصارمه
واخيرا رفعت تلك السياسه الصفريه الجاثمه
على صدورهم في مطلع ديسمبر وباتوا وكانهم
استسلموا لانتشار الفايروس او ربما قرروا
مواجهته مهما كلف الامر ومهما اكتظت
المستشفيات بالمرضى
حتى ان منظمه الصحه العالميه شكرت شفافيه
الصين حينما اعلنت انها وبعد التخلي عن
سياستها سجلت 60,000 وفاه خلال خمسه
اسابيع كما رصدت اصابه نحو 900 مليون شخص
بالفيروس منذ الحادي عشر من يناير الجاري
اذا نتحدث عن هذه الاصابات بالارقام
الصادمه والتي لم تمنع الصين من الاستعداد
للاحتفال بعام الارنب وفقه التقويم الصيني
وبات المواطنون يتهيئون لاستقبال السنه
القمريه الجديده احتفالات مبهجه تضيء
المدن الصينيه وكان الوباء لم يعصف بها
يوما فلما كان للحزن بين هذه الالوان
الزاهيه وان كانت العدوى
ستتفشى بينهم مجددا اختاروا المواجهه اذا
كما هو حال ملايين صينيين الذين
القطارات والطائرات من اجل السفر الى
قراهم لقضاء عطله راس السنه القمريه
الجديده من دون فرض قيود صحيه على
المسافرين
واحد فاصل اربعه مليار نسمه عدد هائل
تقريبا مليار ونصف كلهم اجتمعوا على رفض
القيود لكنهم سيدفعون الضريبه حتما خاصه
اذا لم تكن الخطوه مدروسه بما فيه الكفايه
الهجره الكبيره للعمال من المدن الى مسقط
راسهم لزياره العائلات ستؤدي الى انتشار
العدوى في المناطق الريفيه اقل تجهيزا
بالخدمات الطبيه كرعايه المركزه واجهزه
التنفس الصناعي
[موسيقى]